What I like to do with the equations written in standard form, is to first put
them into slope intercept form. If I had an equation like this, I would want to
change it to slope intercept form. I would want to get the y alone. So I'd have
3y equals 6 minus 2x. And, really, I could list the negative 2x first. In slope
intercept form, that's the case. The x term comes first. I can make the switch
here, and write my equation like this. Because of the commutative property of
addition and subtraction. 1 plus 2 is the same as 2 plus 1. Likewise, positive 6
minus 2x is the same thing as negative 2x plus 6. Notice that the sign stays
with the term. The 6 is positive. And the 2x is negative. Finally we divide
every term by 3 to get y equals negative 2 3rds x plus 2. Now we can read that
the slope is negative 2 3rds. Pretty great. I can also see the slope by looking
at standard form. The slope is going to be equal to the value of a divided by
the value of b. In this case a is positive to And b is positive 3. So I
substitute 2 for a, and 3 for b. So, we get negative 2 thirds.